merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur gérard cherpion
le président de 7 foyers ministre les
chiffres du chômage sont mauvais ils
sont même catastrophique pour votre
gouvernement mais surtout pour les
français qui est subissent
76 mille cent demandeurs d'emplois de
plus en catégorie à b et c c'est la plus
forte hausse mensuelle depuis 2009 et
répète qu'il y avait des crises un
nouveau record l'inversion de la courbe
s'éloigne encore un peu plus monsieur le
premier ministre vous ministres ont
tenté de justifier cette hausse allant
même jusqu'à invoquer la météo ce n'est
jamais de votre faute
certes ce sont pas les ministres qui
créent l'emploi mais ce sont les actes
de votre gouvernement qui entravent la
création d'emplois
la france est dirigée par un
gouvernement sans cap engageant des
réformes est tout créant des usines à
gaz ne faisant rien contre le matraquage
fiscal qui a lui même mis en place rien
pour le pouvoir d'achat des français
rien contre l'échec scolaire et cette
hausse du chômage intervient alors que
pourtant le gouvernement en
tripatouillant les chiffres ouvre les
vannes de pôle emploi pour des
formations sans avenir avec le plan
50000 formation vous sortez le demandeur
d'emploi des compteurs du chômage la
catégorie d qui regroupe les personnes
en formation a explosé de plus de 13% en
un an afin d'assurer la candidature du
président sortant vous procédez à des
tours de passe-passe statistiques mais
il est vrai que selon l'un de vos
ministres françois hollande envisage de
se présenter malgré une hausse du
chômage reniant là encore l'une de ses
promesses la vérité monsieur le premier
ministre et que votre gouvernement a
abandonné la lutte contre le chômage et
donc 6 millions de français pourtant la
vie quotidienne des français reste
difficile ils vivent avec la peur peur
de la perte de leur emploi pour une part
retrouvé d'emploi peur de ne pouvoir
subvenir aux besoins de leur famille
peur pour l'avenir de leurs enfants
quand le cieux premier ministre allez
vous enfin assumer vos responsabilités
merci la parole est à madame myriam el
khomri ministre du travail d'emploi
l'information professionnelle et du
dialogue social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés
monsieur le député gérard cherpion tout
d'abord vauxion point m'appelle un
adjectif est celui de la décence celui
de la décence parce que vous semblez
oublier
permettez-moi de le dire quel a été le
bilan de nicolas sarkozy en matière de
chômage et vous semblez également
oublier qu'elle a été aussi le bilan de
l'ancien premier ministre entre 95 et 97
la deuxième le deuxième âge et tiff
celui qui me vient c'est celui de la
contradiction aujourd'hui même dans le
monde le président richerdt se félicite
se félicite du plan 500000 formation se
félicite qu'enfin avec les cas nous
avons réussi à converger et à dans la
construction il vous plaît ici c'est une
exigence morale c'est une exigence
sociale c'est une exigence économique de
former des demandeurs d'emploi vous le
savez mais là devant les caméras qu'est
ce que vous dites c'est que ce plan
500000 est là pour truquer les
statistiques voilà la contradiction
voilà quelle est la caricature alors
même alors même que nous nous
retroussons les manches les uns avec les
autres sur les territoires pour offrir
ces formations selon les métiers et puis
enfin vous parler de réformes
courageuses mais pour vous quelques par
le courage c'est qui va être le plus dur
qui va être plus restrictif le plus
justement le plus punitif en direction
le permet de moi vous dire le problème
ce ne sont pas les chômeurs le problème
c'est le chômage oui il y à une hausse
significative au mois d'août oui cette
hausse significative
cette hausse significative ne doit pas
nous faire oublier la trajectoire et le
chemin parcouru oui ou non y at-il eu
des créations nettes dans notre pays
depuis un an oui cent quarante mille
créations nettes après de nombreuses
destructions d'emplois donc nous nous
battrons avec détermination à travers l'
embauche pme à travers le monde